I was actually going to cover this story
earlier in today's show except then
Trump's violent rhetoric was actually
linked to a specific shooting the one in
New Zealand but shortly before the
shooting in New Zealand Donald Trump
issued the type of threat that we hear
from authoritarian dictators about using
the police and the military to crack
down against political opponents which
is of course completely antithetical to
everything that the United States stands
for or at least should stand for this
actually wasn't noticed for a few days
Donald Trump gave an interview to
Breitbart it was early last week in fact
and at a certain point in this interview
he said supporters of his might get
tough on people who oppose him
politically this includes the military
this includes the police and this
includes biker gangs now I'm going to
show you
bright Bart's own transcript of what
Trump said this isn't a summary this
isn't some left-wing website rephrasing
what Donald Trump said this is bright
Bart's transcript of what Donald Trump
said they conducted the interview Donald
Trump said quote it's so terrible what's
happening you know the left plays a
tougher game it's very funny I actually
think that the people on the right are
tougher but they don't play it tougher
okay so far it's unintelligible by the
way Trump goes on I can tell you I have
the support of the police the support of
the military the support of the bikers
for Trump I have the tough people and
they don't play it tough until they go
to a certain point and then it would be
very bad very bad but the left plays it
cuter and tougher so let's put aside for
a second the New Zealand shooting that
took place over the weekend even without
that we now have exactly the type of
comment that we can add to Trump's
subtle and sometimes not so subtle
fomenting of political violence remember
that in the United States political
violence exists almost exclusively by
the right okay this is Trump
sort of
or shadowing physical confrontations I
guess based on what he's saying between
left-wing protestors who are almost
exclusively nonviolent and Donald
Trump's biker gangs as well as the
military and the police now you might
say hold on David Trump says police and
military but he doesn't mean that the
police and military are going to enforce
Trump's political views with violence
they are simply for law and order if the
left becomes violent in their opposition
to Donald Trump income the military and
the police and they will simply enforce
the law wrong okay that's a ridiculous
defense police have a job to enforce the
law period the fact that they support
Trump politically which Trump is
bringing up should have no place or
importance in the fact that if people
break the law the police will step in
now as far as even mentioning the
military the military is not supposed to
be used for domestic law enforcement
period there's something from 1878
called the Posse Comitatus Act
commetators not exactly sure how it's
pronounced which limits the use of the
federal government to use the military
for domestic policy enforcement or
domestic law enforcement when Trump
mentions even the possibility of using
the military in this way it's outrageous
and once again once you talk about as
Trump says the military is on his side
you're wading into very dangerous and
possibly illegal territory and I was
thinking Pat if you look at who uses the
military to enforce their political
positions it's not good company it's
exactly the authoritarian types that
were concerned Trump is so impressed and
enamored with yeah this absolutely
sounds to me like a veiled threat it's
kind of like Trump saying I could beat
you up if I wanted to but I'm going to
show restraint and I'm not going to
I certainly hope it never comes to this
I hope we never see the police and the
military and the biker gangs fighting
against the people but if there is ever
time that it gets to that it may be if
Trump loses the election and
wants to fight back in some way doesn't
want to go down and I hope it never gets
to that but I think we're gonna talk
about that a little later in the show
yeah we are we've talked about that
before and we will talk about it again
and just to put finalize so we've got
the police and the military then the
biker gangs that we're now kind of
getting into the realm of the absurd but
Vladimir Putin has actually used a
Russian nationalist biker gang called
the night wolves who are funded in part
by the Kremlin to do all sorts of
political stuff in Russia it's really
vile it probably impresses Donald Trump
and once again these comments I won't
reexpose but these are the types of
comments that would fall under the
umbrella of stochastic terrorism
publicly demonizing or threatening a
person or group which statistically
makes it likely that someone will go and
act out what it is that is being
suggested in this case political
violence by biker gangs the police and
military against the political opponents
of Donald Trump Donald Trump Strunk
that's an interesting one very dangerous
stuff and I want to hear from you about
it what is your reaction in terms of
Trump's rhetoric to the New Zealand
shooting what is your reaction to Donald
Trump's thinly veiled threats to use the
police and the military and biker gangs
to crack down on political opponents by
the way political opponents that Trump
hasn't even said are violent I mean we
know that most of trumps political
opponents aren't violent the political
violence is coming from the right trumps
not even saying that this would be in
response to violence he's saying this
would be against his political opponents
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show follow
me let me know what you think and we'll
follow up on it later in the week
today's program sponsored in part by our
friends over at zip recruiter hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go we're hiring is simple fast and
smart growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates quickly and that is
zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there they're
powerful matching technology scans that
thousands of resumes to find people who
have the right experience and to invite
them to apply to your job as the
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spots la spotlights
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match and it's so effective that
80% of employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first 24
hours and right now our viewers and
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at the exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman that's zip
recruiter dot-com / PA que ma N one more
time zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman it's
the smartest way to hire